Tradutor: Elena Crescia
Revisor: Maurício Kakuei Tanaka
Há três anos, eu fui convidada
para falar num festival de ideias.
E aí, eu perguntei: "Qual é o tema?"
Me responderam: "Você pode falar
sobre o que você quiser".
E eu falei: "Bem, então
eu vou falar sobre algo
que tem me habitado há algum tempo
e que eu chamei de escrita afetuosa".
Me colocaram para falar
logo depois do almoço, e eu falei:
"Não vai aparecer ninguém".
E daí, eu pedi para o meu marido ir,
para, pelo menos, que ele estivesse ali,
para que eu não falasse
para um monte de cadeiras vazias.
Para minha surpresa, não só a sala lotou,
como meu marido precisou
se levantar e segurar as divisórias
que estavam ameaçando cair.
E aí, eu comecei a ter a percepção
de que aquilo não fazia
sentido só para mim,
de que fazia sentido para o outro.
Vocês devem estar se perguntando:
"Mas o que é a escrita afetuosa?"
A escrita afetuosa não fala
sobre cartas de amor,
mas sobre o amor
que existe em cada palavra.
A escrita afetuosa
é a percepção de que existe alma
em tudo o que você escreve.
Você busca dentro de você,
coloca no mundo,
e o mundo te devolve nesse gesto grande.
É a percepção de que,
na sua escrita, está você,
a forma como você está,
como você está no mundo, quem é você,
como você enxerga o mundo,
e o que você traz dentro de você.
A escrita é primordialmente um encontro,
só que a gente se esquece disso.
E isso nasceu muito da minha percepção,
porque eu escrevia textos,
e as pessoas mandavam mensagens.
"Parece que você está conversando comigo!"
E eu comecei a pensar:
"Qual é a diferença entre um texto
que conversa com o outro,
e outro texto que a pessoa
esquece um minuto depois?"
E eu percebi que isso
tinha a ver com entrega,
com o quanto você
se colocava na sua escrita.
Só que a gente escreve um e-mail,
e acha que aquilo é só técnica,
faz um e-mail frio,
esquece que tem você ali...
Pior de tudo, você esquece que tem
uma outra pessoa do outro lado.
E aí, a gente não promove o encontro.
Por que a gente tem tanta dificuldade
em escrever com tanta alma?
Porque dá medo.
Porque, quando a gente
coloca a gente na escrita,
a gente está nu, a gente se mostra,
e a gente não quer se mostrar.
Eu costumo dizer que a escrita
é como uma piscina,
em que você pode colocar só o seu dedo
ali, para sentir a temperatura,
você pode ir até a beirada e mergulhar,
ou você pode ir até o trampolim
mais alto e pular.
Eu gosto muito desse tipo de escrita,
das escritas que promovem
o mergulho profundo.
Eu costumo dizer que a escrita tem cheiro,
tem som.
E aí, as pessoas me questionam:
"Mas é possível fazer
um texto de escrita afetuosa
sobre economia, política,
esporte, sobre chacina?"
E eu falo: "Claro!
Quem está escrevendo
é um robô ou é uma pessoa?
Porque, se é uma pessoa,
eu sinto muito, mas tem você ali".
Só que a gente nunca se dá conta disso.
Eu lembro que tinha uma aluna
que me questionava muito sobre isso,
porque ela falava que o editor dela
queria ver números, taxas no texto.
E eu falei: "Quem está se escondendo?"
Você está se escondendo atrás dos números,
você não está se mostrando.
Texto é vida, e a gente perde
a chance de contar essa história
quando a gente se esconde
atrás da palavra.
A palavra tem força.
Eu gosto muito de escrever
textos sobre comida
e a relação disso com a vida,
com as minhas memórias,
em que eu conto muito sobre como
a minha relação com a minha mãe
foi sendo moldada e construída
através da cozinha
e dos cheiros que vinham da cozinha.
E hoje a gente está muito acostumado
só com livros que trazem receitas
ou que trazem modos de fazer.
De novo, é automatismo:
a gente não entra nas camadas,
a gente fica na superfície.
Quando tem alguém que fala
sobre saudade, sobre amor,
sobre história através de uma panela
de barro, uma geleia de jabuticaba,
o outro se reconhece ali.
Os textos mais viscerais
foram aqueles em que eu senti
que eu mais encontrei o outro,
porque eu entrei nele,
e ele se enxergou ali,
e aquilo voltou para mim.
Eu me lembro de uma pessoa
que me escreveu para falar
que, inspirada nas minhas narrativas,
teve a ideia de pedir para a mãe
ensiná-la a cozinhar,
a mãe, que estava passando
por um processo de depressão profunda.
E aí, a mãe foi até a cozinha,
pegou os cadernos de receita,
e as duas cozinharam juntas.
E ela me disse: "Depois de muito tempo,
foi a primeira vez que eu voltei
a ver a minha mãe sorrir".
Se isso não é poderoso,
eu não sei o que é.
A palavra é de uma força impressionante,
e o mais triste é que a gente
está desperdiçando a palavra todo dia.
Todo dia a gente desperdiça
no nosso automatismo.
Eu vejo muito, e vocês devem experimentar
isso na "timeline" do Facebook de vocês,
palavras de força,
palavras de histórias fortes
como empoderamento,
disruptivo,
economia criativa,
sustentabilidade.
Essas palavras são fortes.
Mas a gente esvazia, quando a gente
deixa de contar as histórias.
A gente tem que contar as histórias
das mulheres que estão em estado de risco.
A gente tem que contar as histórias.
As histórias estão pedindo
para serem contadas.
A escrita é um reflexo da vida
que você leva todo dia,
só que você acha que ela
só mora no extraordinário,
que você só vai poder
escrever um texto incrível
quando você fizer o caminho
de Santiago de Compostela,
quando você tirar o seu sabático,
ou quando você fizer
uma viagem incrível para a Ásia.
E eu vou te falar que
o extraordinário está no ordinário,
na vida que você leva todo dia,
porque, quando você desliga o despertador,
uma história acabou de acontecer.
A maneira como você coloca os livros
na sua mesa de cabeceira
conta histórias sobre você,
histórias sobre saudade,
sobre escolhas, sobre amores.
E por que a gente não está
contando essas histórias?
De novo,
porque a gente tem medo de se mostrar,
porque a gente fica se camuflando.
E sabe o que a gente está fazendo?
A gente está desperdiçando vida.
A palavra tem que ser intensa,
porque a vida tem que ser intensa.
A mídia adora falar de envelhecimento,
gosta de falar dos cabelos brancos,
da liberdade de usar
a roupa que você quiser.
Hoje, dia 12 de agosto, meu pai
está completando 81 anos.
Está sendo muito difícil para ele
envelhecer, e para eu vê-lo envelhecer.
E eu sinto que o que ele quer saber
é como ele faz para se despedir
da vida sem tanta dor.
A percepção de que a vida
é finita traz isso pra gente.
E sabe o que mais?
A gente não está contando essa história,
porque, toda vez que a gente
mergulha numa história
e conta como ela pede para ser contada,
isso dói,
porque isso a gente
tem que tirar de dentro
e tem que encarar as nossas
próprias dores e os nossos medos.
É por isso que a gente
não é intenso com a escrita.
Só que, para mim, a escrita
é sempre um encontro
e uma relação com o outro.
Sou eu em você, você em mim.
É a percepção de que eu existo em você,
e, se isso não é uma relação de amor,
eu não sei mais o que é.
De novo, escrita é uma relação
de amor profundo
e de humanidade na sua essência.
A escrita afetuosa é isso:
é o encontro com o outro,
o encontro através da palavra.
Escrita afetuosa é semente.
Hoje, sei que não posso mudar políticas,
mas eu posso transformar a vida
das pessoas pela escrita.
Então, que a gente siga
se encontrando na palavra
e que a gente siga espalhando amor por aí.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos) (Vivas)